die synagoge ist ein was die
sicherheitsleute ein sehr hartes ziel
nennen also ein endziel was wirklich
extrem geschützt wird und was eben
terroristen häufig machen wenn sie an
ein eigentliches ziel nicht gekommen ist
dass sie eben ziele um dieses harte ziel
herum angreifen und das scheint hier so
zu sein dass ein jüdisches restaurant
getroffen wurde
was wenn die wenn die wenn die abend
hält der rechtsextremen der dschihad ist
sind mindestens genauso gut ist wie die
synagoge denn es geht ja darum juden zu
treffen es geht darum juden angst
einzujagen und das darf man nie
vergessen es geht darum das jüdische
leben in europa zu zerstören es geht
darum ein signal zu senden einen guten
in europa ihr seid hier nicht sicher ihr
könnt jederzeit zu opfern laden und das
ist das ist die wirklich schlimme
botschaft und das geht über die
eigentlichen opfer hinaus ist mag so
sein dass heute nacht vielleicht nur
eine person gestorben
aber die botschaft das signal der terror
die panik die angst die dadurch erzeugt
wird die trifft im prinzip alle juden
und bin wir als europäer nicht mehr
schaffen dass wir in europa edition
gemeinden aufrechterhalten dann haben
wir wirklich als europa versagt das ist
meine persönliche politische meinung
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren